40 finalists 20 winners $100,000 to drop
out of school and pursue our dreams I'm
Lucy and this is teen Technorati today
is our huge day as a lightning round I'm
kind of planning on winging it a little
bit but it has like the structure is
ready I'm hoping that that goes well you
guys ready for today that's been taking
me so long to just nail down my actual
pitch this is gonna be a completely
different on stage because with all the
lights shining on you right now I am not
nervous but I'll probably change my mind
you obviously don't want to give all
your technical information people just
won't listen to that I have created an
algorithm that I named doc bot where
patients enter information such as
symptoms or demographics these are
simple yes-or-no questions that mimic
questions a doctor would ask his or her
patient oh my god is this first we're
gonna come out or honest and really we
are gonna go through the entire show
flow so you guys get a sense of how
everything is going to work the purpose
behind the lightning round is really the
elevator speech it's teaching them to
concisely talk about their project
within a two minute span sounds like the
mic works as I get closer it gets louder
they are entering into a world that at
times can be incredibly high stress and
seeing how they react to that stress and
if they can handle that stress is
important for us to know
all my fraternity brothers are really
excited for me they all know what's
going on this weekend they've been
texting me non-stop saying how's it
going how the interview go when do you
pitch all that stuff this is what I've
been saying to everyone this entire
weekend hive is a crowd-sourced
supercomputer we take these big pieces
of data when we outsource them to
millions of mobile devices around the
world making every single mobile user an
active contributor to a foreign moving
society my name is oz Prada and have a
co-creator and founder of hive right now
I'm just working on a transpiler
completely unrelated to my pitch it
keeps my mind blowing I'm nervous but I
actually think competing in pageants has
prepared me impeccably for this I've
been trying to figure out how nervous I
should be if you're talking about a
project you're doing for two years
you're not gonna get everything across
in two minutes
obviously now the first centers know the
lesson is try to sound coherent in
between I'm gonna kind of go up there on
stage and just try to make it up as I go
hopefully whatever I make up will end
within two minutes I'm hovering between
157 and 205 consistently it's literal
out I wrote my lightning pitch last
night most of the finalists I've talked
to have not yet written in Transparency
Tolkien open-source software helped
so expensive bathroom is for bathroom
today it's used for pitches I have
something kind of memorized but I
basically don't have a okay now
right now I want to leave a legacy I
want to get on stage and be remembered
for being that kid the kid that made
everyone say huh that's amazing I am so
afraid of getting on stage and running
out of breath and it kind of becomes a
cycle where because I'm nervous now not
be able to breathe I start breathing a
little bit more shallow there was a
moment where I actually got a bucket
because I was afraid someone was going
to vomit if I can get on stage into that
first word out excitedly I know I'll be
fine
don't miss the next episode where we all
present our lightning pitches in the
lightning round and be sure to subscribe
to the wire channel for the next king of
karate
you
[Music]